today we're going to be speaking with
professor paul slovik who teaches
psychology at the university of oregon
and also as president of the decision
sciences research institute in eugene
oregon really great having you on i
appreciate your time
thank you david it's good to be with you
so
maybe to start with
we make decisions as humans about risk
reward all the time in our everyday
lives i think with many of the types of
decisions we make we have the feeling
that we're pretty good at assessing the
level of risk when we are undertaking
these decisions
generally speaking
are humans as good as we think at
assessing risk or or not
um
it depends
if we're in a situation that's uh
familiar to us that we've you know
experienced before and
and and learned from our mistakes
and our successes then i think we're
pretty pretty good if it's a novel
situation uh where the
stakes are high uh then we are uh
challenged particularly if
the likelihood of something very good or
very bad happening is is small and we
have to kind of figure out well you know
how do we how do we deal with this is it
a risk that we're willing to take
and that it's
beneficial for us to take
yeah i mean maybe to think through an
example lots of people are afraid of
flying on commercial aircraft and
there's all sorts of different
statistics that are often presented by
those who extol the safety record of
commercial
aircraft and sometimes they say
here's your risk of death per million
passenger miles flown or
the chance of a fatal crash is you know
some small number and you know if you
told me there was a one percent chance
of a fatal crash i'm not getting on the
airplane i know that that's quite high
i've taken hundreds of flights right so
one out of 100 sounds very high but when
the numbers are smaller it does become
more difficult to think of what that
really means for us doesn't it
uh absolutely and
uh more generally the the numbers really
don't uh communicate very well with us
what's more important is our is our
experience you know and have we
flown and everything's gone okay and
and what do we hear on uh on television
or media you know has it been a recent
crash or has been has there been
something that's happened that leads us
to have less trust in the safety of of
airliners like if there's a
like the 737s a few years ago were
mysteriously crashing and and people
didn't know exactly what was going on
well that was scary uh so
so all these things are a factor
that affects our what we call our
feeling of risk because most of the time
we we take
risks depending on how we how we feel
about it whether whether we're worried
or scared as opposed to
uh
whether the statistics uh you know
seem okay to us yeah i mean thinking of
the airplane example
you often hear you're more likely to get
into an accident and die driving to the
airport then on the plane
but it certainly doesn't feel that way i
think to lots of people so that seems to
be the psychological uh layer to it
right so there's a lot of things going
on there when you're when you're driving
you feel you know you're in control
of the risk and you are partially in
control although not as much as you
think you are because there are other
drivers on the roads and there may be
some bad conditions on on the roadway
and so forth but you feel in control
when you're on the plane you know that
you know you're not controlling that
plane and
so you have to trust
the pilots and the system uh these days
many of the planes are being flown
you know by computer
but doesn't you know we don't see that
when it comes to something like covid19
there's been a lot of interesting
websites where
you can plug in a variety of different
data about yourself and about a scenario
in which you're thinking of putting
yourself and the idea is it will spit
something out to you
uh objective that you can then use to
determine whether it's a safe enough
situation for you or not so of course we
know age and pre-existing conditions are
risk factors for getting very sick with
covet we also know that it spreads more
easily indoors than outdoors and i did
one of these before our interview
and i can keep feeding information right
how many people am i going to be around
are they vaccinated am i indoors or
outdoors will the encounter be one two
or three hours all these different
things and then it tells me your risk is
a three out of ten it seems like it's
very difficult to really turn that into
actionable uh intelligence in a sense i
mean it's so detailed but at the same
time what do i do with that information
uh absolutely first i'm not sure how
many people use use these sites yeah uh
most of the time we're just uh operating
again on on our experience and
and uh you know how much
how important it is for us to do you
know to have this meeting or to to go to
this event and this sort of thing and
and again we're using we're using our
feelings uh more than any statistic sure
we know that in general if we're older
uh or we have a pre-existing condition
that makes us vulnerable that we have to
be more careful and i think people are
sensitive to that and are trying to
monitor that and and and be careful but
i think
more generally we as we see you know
very few people are taking uh
precautions right now we see a few
people wearing masks and
it's like it's like it doesn't exist
anymore even though covet is still
still uh quite uh prevalent uh you know
we're told that the uh the effects are
not as serious as the early versions and
and we feel pretty comfortable going
about our business as though things were
normal even though they're not but again
it's not really a matter of statistics
it's a matter of of how we feel about it
and the the thing about our feelings is
sometimes they they deceive us
you know we can't always trust them
yeah the interesting thing about the the
back to normal covid feelings that you
talk about you know i don't remember if
it's daniel dennett or daniel kahneman
who had a particular heuristic that they
they wrote about
but there's this kind of familiarity
where once covet is no longer something
new and we've been living with the risk
for a period of time even if we have not
necessarily been actually engaging in
risky behavior ourselves it sort of
becomes background in a sense where this
is now part of the status quo of life
and it seems that may allow people to
feel as though the risk has lessened
even though it really hasn't maybe we've
just gotten more used to it
yes that uh that definitely happens so
um we're pretty comfortable with the
seasonal flu that you know
and
even though it could be serious a lot of
people got pretty sick and some died you
know it was something that we uh we we
lived it with and became kind of
normalized so these things become
normalized unless something special
happens just like gun violence i mean
gun violence in this country
has become normalized but every once in
a while we have some sort of unusual and
horrific event like we have in recent
weeks in highland park illinois and
buffalo that shakes us out of that and
says wait a minute you know this is
different and we start to pay attention
for a while
and then uh and then it's sort of uh our
concern uh fades away there's sort of a
window of when we're suddenly awake to
the problem and concerned about it wants
something done
and then uh
and then over time that window starts to
to close so
so again this is the way our our
feelings uh go you know that
that these events can shake us out of
our what we call our psychic numbing at
least for a while and that's the window
when action needs to be taken it seems
also there's the other side where for
example after 9 11
people's perception of the risk of for
example being on a hijacked plane or
being the victim of a terrorist attack
was also much higher than the real risk
as well
uh yes
and
you know what we know is that
that if the consequences are very you
know imaginable and scary you know again
that that creates a uh just thinking
about those consequences uh sends a
strong feeling of worry or anxiety you
know through into our brain and then um
then it doesn't really matter what the
probability is that is that is our brain
can't can't moderate a feeling by a
probability unless you unless that
probability is so low that you could
call it zero right zero you don't worry
about it but as long as you've got that
feeling that's driven by the
consequences
you
it feels as though it's likely
and it doesn't matter whether it's a one
percent chance or a ten or a forty
percent those numbers don't matter
because you're thinking of the
consequences and you're feeling at risk
and we we call that you know probability
neglect
you know that
that we're not sensitive to to the
different levels of probability
probability even though those are
important you know uh it really makes a
difference if the chance is one in a
million or or or one in ten one you know
this sort of thing but but uh it's hard
for us when we're going on our feelings
to make those distinctions we need to
think uh analytically and and and step
away from our feelings and think about
well what is this probability you know
and is
and and how likely is it and what's it
compared to other probabilities
that we that we encounter and know
something about so it's a very
complicated dance that our brain does
between feelings and reason
a couple other things i want to ask
about you mentioned this psychic numbing
one of the things that you have worked
on and and elaborated is this idea of
the
psychophysical numbing the idea that if
people hear about a lot a level of loss
of life for example that's an
extraordinarily large number that it
actually becomes more difficult to
connect to it with connect to it on an
emotional level and one of the things
i've talked about from a media analysis
standpoint is that one of the reasons
why a shooting with three victims gets
more media attention than death from
hunger in africa is that the story has a
defined beginning middle and end and
that makes it good for corporate media
but there's a whole other aspect to this
that relates to your work which is to
some degree if you hear
7 000 children a day or dying from
hunger that it's we intuit that it's an
extremely high number but we're not
necessarily connecting to it uh
empirically in the way that we do to the
three shooting deaths to some degree is
that roughly what you have found
uh yes uh we we uh we we have a
saying that that summarizes both what
we've
found in
laboratory research and what we know
from looking outside our window at
what's going on and that is that the
more who die the less we care it's a
rather uh startling
realization and that is you know that
that that we we care a lot about
individual lives and we'll do a lot to
rescue someone to protect uh an
individual particularly if we're if we
if we know their name i know them
personally know their names see their
face and so forth you get an emotional
connection to that that life and it's
very important to protect you don't get
that emotional connection to the
statistics right you know
someone once said uh statistics are
human beings with the tears dried off
you know and
and so you have to you have to to work
at it to think about the individual
lives beneath the surface of those
statistics
yeah one of the things that some of
these charities that work on hunger in
africa have done is
they tell you that when you make a
contribution you'll get pictures and
information about the specific person
that's being helped by your donation
whether it's true or not it seems that
they're working on the idea that you're
talking about here
uh yes they they recognize that as do
reporters who often you know try to you
know humanize the story by talking about
individual victims in a larger uh
tragedy like the school shootings you
know they you see up close and personal
something about the the individual lives
and and that uh that does uh that does
make a difference
last thing i i'd like to ask you about
you've done work on the um i believe
it's called the psychometric paradigm of
risk perception which relates to
if we have positive or negative feelings
about a certain activity
it affects our perception of how risky
it is so if for example you really like
motorcyc be riding a motorcycle you
might perceive that it is more safe
actually to ride a motorcycle than it is
in reality can you talk a little bit
about that
yes that again results from our relying
on our feelings as opposed to uh
statistics
so if if uh if
if you like something you have a
positive feeling towards it
then
then it feels safer you know it feels
like the is very beneficial and the the
risk is low if you dislike something
then you're likely to view it as high in
risk and low in benefit regardless of
what the statistics say uh so for
example with regard to uh to medicines
or i'm sorry with regard to chemicals
there are chemicals we we
tend to think are good chemicals like
medicines and bad chemicals like
pesticides right so we rate pesticides
we start with our feeling that we
dislike them and so we judge them as
high in risk and low in benefit even
though pesticides have a lot of benefits
the same thing with with medicines
we we tend to have more favorable view
of medicines so we judge them as very
beneficial and low in risk even though
some medicines can be very dangerous so
we so it starts with our feelings and
then we derive our sense of risk and
benefit from those feelings what's the
right way to assess risk if there is
such a sense i mean do we need experts
are expert assessments
better than than laypersons or how can
we sort of account for all of these
biases
um the right way is to
is to
try to uh
learn when we can trust our feelings and
when we when we can't and we just
discuss
the situation we can't trust our
feelings is when the number let's just
say we get statistics that are large
right and complex the other is we we
need to we need to rely on experts you
know absolutely we we need to to kind of
uh but we also need to uh to evaluate
what we're hearing you know with our
feelings does you know does does does it
what the person is saying does it feel
right is there are there sources are
there data you know does that seem uh
valid and so forth we need both of these
ways of thinking uh what kahneman calls
fast thinking you know with our gut
feelings and slow thinking with you know
analysis and trust in experts uh we need
to do that we have need to we need to
look for trusted experts to help us in
these complex situations
we've been speaking with dr paul slovik
who's a professor of psychology at the
university of oregon really appreciate
your insights on your time today
thank you very much david